زلازل ضربت فيما سبق نيبال اندونيسيا
وايران وغيرها من البلدان فاحالت احياء
ومدن كامله الى ركام
وهذه لقطات لهزات اصابت اليابان رغم
الاضرار الا ان مباني طوكيو الشاهقه
وغيرها من مدن الارخبيل لا تتعرض للانهيار
السر مدفون تحت امطار من الاسمنت المسلح
هذه القوائم المطاطيه الضخمه قادره على
امتصاص الموجات الزلزاليه التي تتجاوز سبع
درجات على سلم ريختر خبره اليابان مع
الزلازل طويله نظرا لوجوده على الحزام
الناري وهو من اكثر خطوط الصدع التكتونيه
خطوره في العالم لكثره البراكين والبؤر
الزلزاليه فيه ما يفوق 1500 زلزال يضرب
بلاد الشمس المشرقه كل عام الامر الذي دفع
العلماء الى تطوير تحمي من الاثار المدمره
للهزات الارضيه الاولى تخص المنازل وهي
تبنى بتقنيات تجمع بين مرونه الهيكل العام
وصلابه الجدران الحامله ثاني فئه هي
المباني المتوسطه كالمدارس والمستشفيات
التي تجهز اساساتها بنوابض تخفض اثر
الهزات ب70 الى 80% اما التقنيه الاشهر
فهي التي تستخدم في المباني الضخمه
وناطحات السحاب التي تجهز اساساتها بما
يسمى بالعوازل الزلزاليه يكاد من بها الا
يشعر بالزلازل الخفيفه
انس نماسي العربيه